[Musique
] c'est une histoire un vieil homme très cher vient de
me rattraper il t'attend ce qu'un
employé qui souffre depuis longtemps du
multimilliardaire Lionel shabandar branleur non
il aurait sa revanche sa revendication
reposait sur un faux tableau et une vraie
cowgirl comment  vous aimez faire un demi-
million de livres, oui,
un beau travail,
vous ne soupçonnerez jamais que c'était un faux
meules de foin de Monet depuis des années maintenant que Ravinder le
cherche, c'est avec une passion au
crépuscule des meules de foin, je suppose que Harry
vous a parlé de cette peinture, je suis un homme à moins que
la peinture vaut 12 millions de livres c'est
tout ce qui se passe tu es peut-être mon compagnon de dîner
c'est un peu idiot oh encule-moi
wow c'est ton pantalon hé mec nous avons affaire
à nous pas à propos de mélanger le
professionnel avec le personnel bien
peut-être que je ne le fais pas  l'esprit d'être séduit par un
multimilliardaire alors que je nous ai aidés à
ignorer
je vous ai parlé des courts et bouclés
excellents
allons-y c'est sacrément merveilleux
sans rien oublier d'autre sommes-nous
certains non non monsieur